[Musik]
für kinder sind großeltern meist
großartig ganz ruhiger hand gehabt und
viel mehr gestellt
noch nie waren großeltern so wichtig wie
heute
sie hegen und pflegen ihre enkel und es
gibt solche die machen fast alles für
sie
dabei hätten sie passwörter face sie
macht alles
und wenn man nicht alles machen will
wenn man die enkel über alles liebt und
dass großeltern seien trotzdem zu einer
last werden kann
[Musik]
das ist ja mein enkel ich bin seine
großmutter aber so möchte ich nicht
reißen
das klingt für mich alt und grau ich tue
mich auch sonst schwer mit meiner
großmutter rolle und finde mich nicht
zurecht jetzt bin ich also wieder im
tierpark es fühlt sich ähnlich an wie
damals mit meinen kindern als sie klein
waren immerhin einen namen habe ich für
mich gefunden
für jahre bin ich die mime und logisch
ich liebe ihn über alles
aber mit meinen ansprüchen und
vorstellungen wie ich als großmutter
sein sollte damit komme ich nicht klar
wie ist es wohl für andere
[Musik]
ich mache mich auf die suche und treffe
andere großeltern und lerne dabei
unglaublich geduldige kennen
[Musik]
familie passiert dann begegne ich
solchen die pullover stricken für die
enkel und trotzdem den mut haben sich
konventionen und erwartungen zu
widersetzen
sie genießen lieber ihren freiraum und
ihre zweisamkeit
[Musik]
eine großmutter nimmt mich mit zur groß
mit der revolution wo frauen offen auch
überragend großmütter reden
[Musik]
großmütter können ganz schön schräg sein
werde ich hier erfahren
meine suche führt mich auch aufs land wo
es kaum strukturen für die
kinderbetreuung gibt dafür umso mehr
väter omas und flotter opfers
wir sind im zürcherischen coburg die
großeltern sind bei alexander und nis zu
hause jede woche nehmen christina und
françois höpflinger eine stunde anreise
in kauf um ihre enkel zu hüten jetzt
[Musik]
schon mal probieren statt kokosnuss gibt
es ein sandwich mit zwieback und mehr in
sandwich mit kreationen
ja denn diese bundes und müssen bevor
wir überhaupt ist
während die eltern zu hause zum rechten
schauen
arbeitet die tochter an der universität
anna-katharina höpflinger ist
religionswissenschaftlerin zu diesem
zukauf pilgern hat meines erachtens die
kamera gewisse chancen
[Musik]
sie hatte ein 50 prozent pensum arbeitet
aber meist mehr fünf minuten eure
resultate diskutiert dass wir dann
zusammen die film abschnitten noch mal
anschauen und sammeln
zwei tage in der woche lebt christina
höpflinger im haus der tochter und deren
familie
[Musik]
sie ist 65 sozialarbeiterin und erst
seit kurzem pensioniert selber hat sie
zwei kinder großgezogen und immer
gearbeitet
ihr mann ist françois höpflinger
generationen forscher und emeritierter
professor für soziologie
er kann hier sein theoretisches wissen
quasi in der praxis überprüfen
familien und dem computer das relativ
klassisch überhaupt sind
fußgänger gilt als der alters und
generationen forscher im
deutschsprachigen raum und hat als
erster in der schweiz die großeltern
schafft erforscht
[Musik]
in seinen studien belegt er die
beziehung zwischen enkeln und großeltern
ist auf einem höhepunkt noch nie waren
großeltern so wichtig so fit und ihnen
die enkel betreuung eingebunden wie
heute dass so viele trage ich sich aktiv
engagiert und auch die bezirke äußert
und umtausch möglich so gute beziehung
hat sich an kindern großeltern
praktische älterer personen und ihren
eigenen kind also das ist eine summe von
340 your gar nicht hüttlinger hüten die
enkel seit geburt ohne sie hätten die
eltern von nils und alexander ein
problem
im dorf gibt es keine kindertagesstätte
[Musik]
françois höpflinger hat zusammen mit
anderen fachleuten ausgerechnet
großeltern leisten in der schweiz über
100 millionen betreuungsstunden
umgerechnet wären das etwa 50.000
vollzeitstellen
wenn in ländlichen regionen wie keyboard
kindertagesstätten fehlern muss die
familie einspringen und das heißt meist
die kinder werden dann von ihren
großeltern betreut ein großer tag für
meinen enkel jahre er wird zwei meine
tochter und diamant sind beide
berufstätig wie die meisten jungen
eltern heute alle ihre kolleginnen
erfahre ich hier am fest haben eltern
die ihre enkel regelmäßig hüten
es scheint mir als ob das heute üblich
sei fast eine pflicht und ich frage mich
woher nehmen die anderen großeltern nur
die zeit und die kraft fürs hüten
jetzt lacht sie darüber aber sie fand
mich tatsächlich schwierig damals als
ich hier angeboten hatte jahre
regelmäßig zu wüten
einmal in der woche immer am donnerstag
war er bei mir
es war schön zugleich fand ich es sehr
anstrengend
es war mir zu viel nebst arbeit und
allem und ich habe es nicht geschafft
darüber zu reden
meine tochter hat ist ein angesprochen
den ersten großmutter mutter klatsch
haben wir damit hinter uns ganz gewöhnt
leute und der wirklich schwierig wird
oder wie sowie mieter verpflichtet ich
habe doch am meisten bringen holen und
werden
ich glaube selbst ich sage ja darunter
automatisches hinweg gern dass das ist
große nanometer also merkel sieht die
namen wie ich bin von andere irgendwo
verletzt
dass gold immer so höher warum meinen
eigentlich viele großeltern hätten eine
menge freie zeit sein portioniert und
würden nur darauf warten die enkel hüten
zu dürfen
in der schweiz wird man im schnitt
zwischen 53 und 55 großmutter das sind
die meisten noch berufstätig der
landgasthof bären in madiswil eine uhr
jeweils mit hotel die schon in vierter
generation in den händen der familie in
gold ist es ist mittwoch
wie immer bringt tochter million kommen
ihre kinder zu den eltern zwei tage sind
die kinder dar inklusive übernachtung
jede woche im bären haben sie ein
eigenes zimmer perfekt und liebevoll
eingerichtet von chroma e learning gault
millau ist zwei talenten 4 und croma
eliane 59 auch wenn die enkel da sind
der ganze betrieb muss weiterlaufen
[Musik]
eliane und jörg in gold sind im bären
voll engagiert schon als ihre kinder so
klein waren haben sie den bären geführt
sie kennen das damals wie heute eine
menge arbeit das in einem solch dichten
arbeitsalltag überhaupt noch platz
bleibt für die enkel betreuung alles
eine frage der einstellung sagen die
beiden
[Musik]
hast du und ich
sie machen das bo skovhus nebst den
enkeln ist er auch noch die urgroßmutter
die mutter von jörg in gold die 93
jährige wohnt auch himbeeren und hilft
immer noch im betrieb mit eliane in gold
schafft trotz ihres 100% engagement sin
bären den spagat zwischen betreuern und
betrieb führen
[Musik]
der perren muss für die enkel ein
paradies sein für die berufstätigen
großeltern bedeutet er meist 1 15
stunden arbeitstag
[Musik]
bei ingolf sind die rollen klar verteilt
clapper jörg in gold ist der chefkoch
und schaut dass der betrieb trotz in
köln weiter läuft
wenn's geht betreut coma eliane in gold
an den zwei tagen ausschließlich die
enkel
sie seien ganz normale großeltern
betonen die beiden
für mich sind sie aber außergewöhnlich
also das ist alles was ich eigentlich
mehr aber das ist natürlich du musst
immer brisant sie beherrsche
mittagsschlaf für überstunden und das
ist super aber der ton ihm eingezogen
ich glaube die haben das ist eine decke
sich aber mit den großen extrem
ist das thema nicht klingen sie deswegen
aber für konsequenzen
[Musik]
das ist genau besonders blick sowie
eliane in gold aus madiswil so müsste
ich sein das ist mein idealbild von
einer großmutter und was bin ich eine
gelegenheit großmutter
taxiert
[Musik]
erst seit ich selber großmutter bin sehe
ich rund um mich herum die vielen
großeltern die ihre enkel hüten dass
junge mütter und väter heute beide
arbeiten ist selbstverständlich aber mit
den betreuungsstrukturen hinken wir
hinterher aber ist es in ordnung dass
alle mit uns großeltern rechnen
der staat die gesellschaft die eigenen
kinder
das ist meine mutter die urgroßmutter
von jahren als ich noch klein war wäre
meine mutter wohl nicht auf die idee
gekommen ihre eltern zu fragen ob sie
mich und meine geschwister kühlten
würden
ich erinnere mich großeltern das waren
für mich primär alte leute
solltet ihr immer wieder zeigen was sie
da hinten wie die großeltern bezug hat
zu senken
die sind einfach zu sache als betrachter
aber sagt man nicht so viel gemacht
die nähe wie ich sie in meiner mutter zu
ihrem urenkel hat so was gab es früher
nicht
als wir klein waren zählten zur familie
primär die eltern und die geschwister
die großeltern sollen wir wenig und oft
nur an die familien anlässen die
beziehung zu ihnen was sich ja herzlich
aber distanziert
[Musik]
das war früher so üblich sagt mir
françois höpflinger der die großeltern
schafft auch historisch untersucht hat
zwar historisch so sexy dass großeltern
lange zeit habe ich bin damit fertig vom
bürgerlichen idealen foto kosten von
großvater wünsche massaker historische
funde als teil von familie system ob er
so witzig als passive personen als lead
award zur familie gehört aber nicht
inaktiv hohle hand die der familie sind
taxi wolfgang sasse sind gespeichert hat
vielleicht mehr zeit hat aber eigentlich
eher im hinteren sie der tempelberg
einen bezug zu den engen bucht
oberschicht hat zum teil und gewisse
dinge rational sein handwerk legt die
dem hochaltar und das als 80 sehr hoch
sie handkraft und sind schon so alt sind
dann kauft man hat mit jungen oder für
die jetzt den grünen mitdenken mitmachen
gehört haben und gewitter sind genauso
snowboarder mit mankel sohn oder auch
das ist früher möglich sie und das ist
ganz klar
entwickelt von der sehr distanzierter
bezirk zu einer sehr emotional positive
anbieter beziehen
die frauen hier möchten ein neues
großmutter bild prägen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich bin an einem kongress der großmütter
revolution einer plattform vom
migros-kulturprozent initiiert und
unterstützt
hier treffen sich frauen die sich mit
dem lebensabschnitt zur großmutter
generation gehören auseinandersetzen
[Musik]
heidi witzig hat die großmütter
revolution mitbegründete sie hat sich
schon immer für die anliegen der frauen
eingesetzt und lässt sich auch im alter
nicht davon abhalten ihr anliegen ist
vor allem ein politisches weniger
unterschiede wird sondern einfach die
alte generation aber du musst du musst
immer wissen es geht je höher das
geschirr älter das wird umso tür sowie
exklusive listung für diese frauen ja
mal dass er politisch aktiv sind und
sich als kosmonaut politisch
positionieren
wir sind da die erste generation wo
jetzt alt worden ist wo also zumindest
30 oder so stimmrechte also da heißt
ihres zieles schaue jetzt als großmutter
klasse politisch aktiv zu verständlich
also ich bin ich sage das will ich bin
eine alte politische herr sinn mache
daher hauptsächlich also ich mache
tatsächlich politisch ist auch katar
es gibt aber eine freiwillige machen
sollte wenn die kulturelle oder treffen
sich oder
in den kritiken welche projekt andere
und so mache da machen lust hat diese
chance packe ich und suche spontan
frauen die mit mir überragen großmütter
reden möchten
ein schwerpunkt der groß mit der
revolution es werden gesprächsgruppen
gebildet zu verschiedenen themen von
politik über körper bis hin zur psyche
mein thema stößt auf interesse
ich finde gleichgesinnte mit moralischen
etwaige behaftet die ganze die ganze
kroos minute geschafft denkbar einfach
damit mit tdi und das mittel zur
verfügung stellen wenn es alle geholt
dass man das machen
betrug das finde ich dass wir mit tempo
um gottes moneybookers verplant werden
ja klar am morgen früh manager der am 7
immerhin sondern großmütter und mango
baden großvater die leistung erbrachte
fotografierte ich finde gott jetzt in
die nähere umgebung sind ja alle so
focke packende und hörte großmutter
werfen möchte und ich kann keinen kuchen
backen und hörte ich auch nicht wer bin
ich denn denn und wenn ich mal was
kritisches problem - wählen gar nichts
fiel den jahrgängen aber auch wir sauber
image wurden mitgenommen haben und ich
denke mal dass ich den worten ich mich
[Musik]
also doch ich bin nicht allein mit
meinen zweifeln einem schlechten
gewissen und meinem dilemma
[Musik]
großmütter reden einfach noch zu wenig
darüber
da bin ich immer schlecht
das buch wird das buch selbstbewusst sie
das braucht auseinander sechziger das
punkt dass man merkt es stimmt für mich
wenn ich nein sagen und das war unser
auftrag
[Musik]
esther kraus hat vier kinder großgezogen
und hat vier enkel
die 70 jährige ist erst seit kurzem
portioniert und hat jetzt endlich mehr
zeit fürs rudern aber von ihr wird
erwartet dass sie ihre enkel hütet so
wie es viele ihrer freundinnen tun
sie möchte stattdessen lieber rudern als
fahrer ins auto bild wo abnehmer ort und
das irritiert mich im moment eine
verschiedene ebenen durch verschiedene
gewählt das einfach die roma die
rot-weißen etwas was man erwartet was
überhaupt ein garni und erlaubt ohne
dass die andere irritiert werden das ist
extrem aufwändig als das instrument ist
wie reagieren da heißt sie dachten wir
ja wieder alles machen wie man die
letzte generation wieder metros abend
war mehr ausbrachen
friedrich
[Musik]
wir sind bei esther klaus zu hause
hier hatte sie ihr büro als 40-jähriger
hat sie damals eine firma im bereich
service design aufgebaut hat viel
gearbeitet und war oft unterwegs
jetzt ist sie dabei ihrer firma
aufzulösen
[Musik]
mit ihrer man wohnt sie in diesem haus
sie haben hier ihre vier kinder
großgezogen jetzt sind sie alleine jörg
tauss ist jurist und auch funktioniert
er arbeitet immer noch viel aber
ausschließlich ehrenamtlich bester klaus
habe ich an der großmütter revolution
kennengelernt
sie ist auch eine suchende die mit sich
und den ansprüchen ringt und sie ist
mutig spricht über themen wie heikel
sind auch sie hütet ihre enkel hin und
wieder
sie hat ihren kindern aber gesagt dass
sie sich nicht verpflichten lassen wie
reagieren ihre kinder begleiten das
einfach überklebt und betraten das
familienzentrum problem familie wie sie
findet musik so wird deren erwarte ich
nicht gedacht dass man sich die macher
und vor allem es wird irgendwo vor allem
energie zu der kinder so zu der familie
und das geht sicher dass wir das so
machen und das sind das ist gut aber ich
suche eigentlich dienen
alle diese mit viel schalk fehlerhaft
wenn sie sich so abgrenzen dass ich höre
ja nicht noch vor ihnen
es gibt ja viele frauen auf der einige
fahrer sagte jurack ein wenig traurig
ja das ist schwierig also ich empfinde
das als schwierig ich merke immer wieder
jetzt furchtbar gern irgendwie quasi die
ausstellung auch ohne familie kann aber
das nicht getraut
natürlich ist sie waren die großen
kämpfe austragen so überschüttet und
auch ist das schön so idyllisch und
eigentlich gerne mal aus aber jetzt ins
fernsehen
das macht also ich meine sich thomas
aber eigentlich wäre was jetzt daraus
von mir irrsinnig groß ist ja aber es
schaut dann genau wie die drei kinder
wenn du bist für die große hat die dich
nicht gern
eine angst die auch mir vertraut ist die
angst abgelehnt zu werden wenn man
ehrlich mit sich und anderen ist
[Musik]
wir hier den clip fiaskos vater sagte
ich kann und ich bis jetzt nur negatives
gehört direkt größten großen älteren
also ich hätte das nie mehr machen aber
das galt vor allem richtig mit mini hdmi
es ist der wald ist halt nicht so groß
die namen einfach die rola hat der
großvater unter dem wiener kritisiert
grosz also ihre frau also die
erwartungshaltung außenspiegel
wenn von großeltern die rede ist meinte
man meist die großmutter die krippe
große und wenn frauen nein sagen sind
sie schnell keine guten großmütter mehr
[Musik]
esther und jörg tauss haben viel
gearbeitet und viel erreicht jetzt sind
beide über 70 und möchten das erreichte
genießen endlich zeit haben für sich und
als paar
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mir geht es ja eigentlich ähnlich ich
habe zwei kinder großgezogen immer viel
gearbeitet auch jetzt noch
und wenn ich frei habe dann hätte ich
die zeit gerne für mich und gleichzeitig
möchte ich viel näher zu meiner familie
ich muss nur noch das richtige maß
finden hüten ohne zwang und fixe
verpflichtungen das wäre das beste
verein
altersforscher françois höpflinger sagt
freiwillig enkel hüten sei die beste
voraussetzung für eine gute beziehung
zwischen den generationen
[Musik]
das sind 73 zähler
einigkeit und support tiere werden wir
brauchen blut
es kommt der profis eltern und betreuer
oder ob sie team betreuen
denn allein da wo sie treffen sind
einfach sind
denn täglich und das wohlbefinden für
ältere menschen positiv beeinflusst
etwas ermüdet führt das amt zu konflikt
und zum ausstieg
also man ist ja das ist schon so dass er
seine aufgabe freiwillig sagt sie und
münsters bildungsstudie nutzer an land
und den usa ist sehr viel großeltern
handel erzielt haben das ist
sie belasten die es sieht dort sowie
dazu gekauft haben darf sich jetzt wohl
endlich auch die kümmerer
[Musik]
enkelkinder halten großeltern aber auch
fit
du hast gut sie sind sozusagen ein
jungbrunnen
[Musik]
wir sind schnell ganz gültig für mit
fenster sind aber mit einem genau
beobachtet was passiert dann ist es so
dass großeltern lerntyp wird über neue
technologien neue entwicklungen neue
sprache als umgekehrt
der prozess läuft reform zu als
umgekehrt
also das heißt alle die wert nur noch
1000 personen erweitert die sind gar
nicht so wichtig
ihr werdet das geschäftliche emotion
dass dort oft betonen aber russischen
und auto mit deutschland als betonen
aber was hinter den kulissen passiert
ist besonders
und das ist schon so dass zum teil
mehrere generationen vorstand wohl
wissend dass 20 lernen mit neuen
technologien mit neue soziale zittern
und gordon anders laufen als gestrandete
reisende aus personen was ihre
gesellschaft in der sie leben ihren
begriffen
[Musik]
arbeiten mit der gewissheit dass die
kinder gut versorgt sind
das ist schier unbezahlbar und so
flexibel und kostengünstig wie es die
großeltern sind das kann an der krippe
nicht bieten
das junge eltern müssen heute nicht mehr
entscheiden zwischen kindern und der
arbeit auf dank der vielen mütter
schwiegermütter und großväter
[Musik]
sollen die großeltern den preis für die
freiheit ihre kinder und wären
großmütter so nicht wieder in ein altes
rollenbild gedrängt als städtische sieht
ein fall der das neue muster so man hat
alles können verwirklichen im leben und
plötzlich haben sich vielleicht sachen
wo man aber noch nicht entdeckt also im
zweifel haftpflicht wirklich was zu
sagen dass sie aus als mutter zu kind
also es ist gespräche geben aber
vielleicht die chance ich will es nicht
mal negativ das ist eine sk freja oder
niedrigen vor wichtigste chance und
holte blog dass wenn ich jetzt kreativ
rock dort hat sie das casino im stechen
klicks ist wirklich bio schaffen und die
kinder und stress hat und das ist
möglich dass er bisher nicht bestimmen
und die heime 1 kommentar es ist schon
befremdlich ist dass ich unter der
bewährten aber für sie ja ganz praktisch
einfach riesig enttäuscht wir haben auch
dürren oder müller enorm entlasten aber
beruhigen
ja auf jeden fall
[Musik]
doch durch das mehr benutzt wie so
fernanda quizshow hat sich bezirks
qualität verändert hätten
jede generation hat eigenen haushalt
altersabhängig verdient
dadurch können wir nicht auf und ab geht
vor - hand in hand durch das niedrige
nahezu selbstständig ist selbständig an
handler dank verantwortlich für sich
selber habe bestritt dass faktisch den
generationen bezirke verbessert worden
sind das schreiben eigentlichen
forschungsresultate profitiert
die profitiere von einer neuen
konstellation eliane in gold macht
wieder drei sachen gleichzeitig wie
immer mit einer engelsgeduld
die beziehung zwischen enkeln großeltern
läuft nur wenn die beziehung zu den
eigenen kindern gut ist in gold
investieren in die familie
das ist für beide nicht arbeit oder mehr
aufwand sie tun es aus überzeugung und
mit freude groß eltern leisten in der
schweiz pro jahr für umgerechnet über
zwei milliarden schweizer franken
betreuungsarbeit gemessen an diesem
enormen einsatz erhalten sie vom staat
und von der gesellschaft noch zu wenig
anerkennung
das muss aus dem regal klang mit
schlacht von vista jeder wenn er
ähnliche funktion hierzu müssen erklären
was heißt das von oben
56 ja ja das meiste mit lernen und das
ist natürlich cool vendor
klosterreichenbach zuvor schon von der
idee ab
der prozess dann usa
[Musik]
tochter milenko man arbeitet als
lehrerin nach zwei tagen holt sie ihre
kinder jeweils nach der arbeit wieder ab
[Musik]
wenn sie noch zweiter
er vergleicht kann man hier
es braucht ja ja ja ja sie machen ja das
ist es was die verdienen kann mit denen
spieler gab es ebenso gut der heute frei
weniger im büro ja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wenn wir so engagiert ist im tv das
zurück und vertritt bis zu rock und
aberwitz militärs thema - und immer dass
sie sich sehr gut aus sagt verständlich
warum ein geschützter und jedoch auf
zwei schienen für muss vorbereitet dafür
dass sie dahinter trucker oder die
anlage tag und es ist noch nie gegangen
und hat nicht mehr sie mal mehr oder
messi und verflucht eine gute beziehung
zu den kindern und den enkeln kann auch
eine absicherung für den letzten
lebensabschnitt seien für weniger
einsamkeit im hohen alter
esther kraus und ihr mann sind sich
bewusst dass ihre abgrenzung vielleicht
auch mehr allein sein bedeuten kann
ich habe mir sozialabbau monopoly frau
lobby der familie wollte das nicht so
etwas schwierigkeiten kehrt ja dann
zahle ich hatte pries aber so quasi zum
gurtwarner machen
jetzt muss er mit der zur bringe wie sie
gerne machen
ja ja ja ich muss also auf das auslegen
dass ich gefragt wie sie etwas milch
interniert sie mit mir ins auto so
auslegen dass ich auch erleichtert
werden
also das ist für mich nicht zwingend
dass man total sind wenn ich alt bin ich
finde die abhängigkeit das wirklich gar
nichts
also ja und so großen hochhalten
dieser war nicht weil es für sie radtour
in dem sinn dass ich sage es mit ihnen
bis hamid gehe dann mache ich das gern
aber ich kann einfach druck das war
nicht die eigenständigkeit der mini wenn
ich jetzt aus wien über zürich ist wenn
ich das lag waren einfach credo das gibt
ihnen mit auf eine rettende bis man
überhaupt für mich stimmt
[Musik]
selber darf ich einen ersten blick auf
meinen zweiten enkel werfen habe ich die
situation erst jetzt allmählich im griff
und schon die nächste herausforderung
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die kinder von heute werden einmal ein
ganz anderes bild von ihren großeltern
haben und wenn sie dannzumal sagen
werden unsere großeltern waren immer
herzlich ehrlich und sorgsam mit sich
und mit uns das wäre doch wunderbar
[Musik]